AMD Radeon 960 XT. I'm quite excited
about this one. Well, I'm excited about
the 16 gigabyte model at least, which is
what we have here for review. Needless
to say, as with the 8 GB 5060Ti, we
don't recommend the 8 GB 960 XT. Now,
$350 notionally gets you the 16 gig 960
XT. And that's the one that I'm really
interested in checking out today,
principally because its competition is a
$430 Ti, which offers proportionately
less value than the
$55070. Now, if AMD can provide an
alternative that's just as powerful and
has the required 16 gigs of memory and
delivers the right value, well, I think
that's pretty cool. I think it's a
winner. And when we enter that level of
performance, a curious thing happens. A
$350 GPU is delivering the kind of
horsepower found in Sony's $700
PlayStation 5 Professional. The card I'm
looking at today is the Sapphire Pulse
Edition. And to be frank, I'm glad AMD
sent this one for review as opposed to a
premium factory overclocked version.
It's better representative of the cards
you're likely to get. And I've no real
complaint with this one. Whisper quiet
in operation. One PCIe 8pin input, two
display ports, one HDMI 2.1. Basic to
the point, not overengineered. Exactly
what I like in this market sector.
Specs- wise, much the same is true. You
can think of the 1960 XT as almost
literally half a 9070 XT. 4,096 shaders
across 64 compute units
becomes48 over 32. A
256bit memory interface good for 640 GB
pers of bandwidth becomes 128 bit for
320 GB pers. However, the 9060 XT's TGP
total graphics power is higher than
half. And clock speeds are also higher,
quite a bit higher. Boost clocks and
game clocks, I suppose they're good for
official spec comparisons, but the
realworld output definitely skews
towards the higher boost clock figure.
In fact, let's start by taking a look at
GPU clock speeds, performance, and power
consumption for the 9060 XT. Stacking it
up against the RTX 5060 and 5060Ti are
obvious comparison points bearing in
mind the pricing. But in comparing it to
another AMD product, uh I found the
vintage 2020 6800 XT to be a very
closeerforming GPU to what the Radeon
team has delivered with the 960 XT,
which should give you some idea of the
ballpark output of the card and of the
big big efficiency improvements between
RDNA 2 and RDNA 4. Let's kick off with
some rasterization data where I've
chosen for Horizon 5 because of all the
benchmarks I had, this is where the 960
XT hits its highest clocks over 3.3 GHz,
though the range can vary quite
dramatically between titles. 9060 XT has
90% of the 5060Ti's performance, but
typically requires 25% more power. The
6800 XT is 10% faster, but requires a
lot more juice to get there. RTX 5060
performance is relatively poor here, but
the efficiency differential is
remarkable. Forza has always been
somewhat strange in benchmarking and
there are better results elsewhere. Here
in Alen Wake 2, for example, clocks are
lower, but the performance differentials
are better. 9060 XT, 5060Ti, and 6800 XT
perform much the same. Again, the Nvidia
card uses less power to get there, but
the 6800 XT uses around 120 W more to
deliver much the same output. I'd
imagine results for the 8 gig 960 XT
would be much the same, meaning a
commanding win for AMD over the 5060,
albeit with higher powered draw. Quick
look at RAID tracing, and you'll see
that GPU core clocks drop significantly
with heavy RT workloads. We're now in
2.8 8 GHz territory, while PowerVore is
now in the 180 W range for this Sapphire
Pulse card. With this game, there's
still clear water between the 5060, but
the Nvidia card consumes a lot less
power. Same thing with the RTX 5060Ti
really, though across the whole
benchmark, it can only 5% more
performance. The circa 120 W
differential with 6800 XT remains in
place, but you're getting 20% higher
throughput. Not bad. Bearing in mind
we're talking about 72 RDNA2 compute
units against 32
RDNA4. RT comparisons against Nvidia
will vary dramatically. However, as you
can see here in Alen Wakeake 2, while
960 XT core clocks are higher, the
existing power differentials remain very
similar. But this time, the new AMD
offering gives performance that's pretty
much identical to the nonTi 5060 across
the length of the benchmark. 5060 Ti is
a good 20% ahead while consuming less
power. That said, the less said about
the problem games we've identified with
the Black Core architecture, the better.
But we'll talk about that in more depth
in the benchmarks to follow. But before
we go on to those numbers, regular
viewers may have seen some pretty
alarming benchmarks in my 5060 review.
Essentially, both 5060 and 5060Ti have
PCIe 8X interfaces havinging potential
bandwidth. No problem on a PCIe Gen 4 or
Gen 5 PC, but definitely a problem on
older Gen 3 systems where bandwidth
between GPU and systems suddenly gets a
lot more constricted. I reran those
tests on the 9060 XT again using my
Ryzen 7 9800 X3D using an ASUS X87E
motherboard which can simulate PCIe3
bandwidth. PCIe Gen 3 is slower than Gen
5, but not in any way that should impact
your purchasing decision. Generally
frame rates were the same or a touch
lower, 1 to 2% lower. There is an
exception, however, F-124. Here with
rate tracing maxed, we lose 3%
performance at 1440p and 4% at 1080p.
The result is actually worse with RT
disabled, a 5% differential at 1440p,
rising to 7% at 1080p. So let's talk
numbers then and we have a full face off
between the three 60class cards Nvidia
has out right now and the 9060 XT which
aims to take out all of them. So RTX
5060 and 5060Ti 8 gig up against Ti 16
gig and the new 9060 XT. Looking at Alan
Wake 2 with RA tracing at 1080p
resolution. I have the 5060 Ti here. uh
15 to 16% faster than 9060 XT which is
essentially offering the same kind of
performance as RTX 5060. RA tracing
therefore remains an Nvidia advantage
not least owing to its traditional
hardware advantage along with deep
integration with developers like Remedy.
So a 16point lead for a card that in its
16 GB iteration costs 22% more.
Something to think about. Still, AMD's
RT game has improved significantly with
RDNA4. And where Nvidia is weak, AMD can
deliver a surprise or two, uh, like here
in Avatar Frontiers of Pandora, a game
that traditionally performs poorly on
the Black Row architecture. Here, the
1960 XT is 10.5% to the better against
the 5060, while the Ti lead is 9 to 10%
ahead, depending on the model.
Interestingly, in my tests, certain
games do seem a touch faster on the 8
gig 5060Ti for some reason. Uh, they can
be the same or slower. Here, 8 GB has a
1% lead, which could be margin of error.
Of course, frame times are definitely
spikier on the 8 GB 5060, though weirdly
not on the 8 GB Ti. Elsewhere though,
Nvidia pulls ahead, sometimes
convincingly so. Both 5060 Ti here are
circa 19% ahead in Cyberpunk
2077. Almost but not quite getting to
price versus performance par here. The 8
GB 5060 is on par with the 9060 XT
across the length of the benchmarking
sequence. Dying Light 2 also offers 14
to 16 percentage points advantages to
5060Ti at 1080p resolution on those high
RT settings. And once again, 9060 XT is
effectively on par with 5060 performance
across the length of the sequence tested
here. You'll note that the two jostle
for position across the bench. AMD is
stronger in less dense areas. Nvidia in
more challenging content. Before we move
on from RT though, some notes on 1440p
benches where the 8 GB models struggled.
Both of these cards have issues at the
beginning of our Alam Wakeake 2 test
scene before leveling out. Meanwhile,
the frame time fluctuations seen with
the 5060 in Avatar Frontiers of Pandora
are worse at
1440p, though the 8 GB Ti still looks
pretty okay here. Meanwhile, in some
areas of our Plague Tale Recquum bench,
both the 8 GB cards here can collapse
while both of the 16 gig cards benched
here just crack on. On to rasterization
then where as the tried but tested
cliche always says we should expect to
see a better showing from AMD. So
returning to Alan Wakeake 2, the 5060
Ti's performance advantage basically
disappears. 9060 XT is marginally ahead
of both 8 and 16 GB cards while
delivering a 17point lead over the
vanilla 5060. Elsewhere though, what
you're generally seeing is 9060 XT
clawing back at 5060 Ti's performance
lead, offering superior frames per
dollar in the process. So here in Hitman
World of Assassination, performance
differentials vary between the scenes,
but at the end of the day, this AMD
friendly game offers a two to three
percentage point lead over the TI, 23
points clearer
5060 force Horizon 5. Next, extreme
settings 8x MSIA. It's a pitch battle
across this sequence with the TI cards
delivering a 3 to 5% performance lead.
9060 outpacing the 5060 by 15%. But
let's finish up with uh the Unreal
Engine 5 Juggerauts in our benchmarking
suite. Kicking off with Blackmmith
Wukong. The 5060Ti claws back some
points here with a 12 to 13 point
advantage over the 9060 XT, but the AMD
offering is just 8 to 9 percentage
points ahead of the 5060. Moving on to
Hellblade 2, the 5060Ti's advantage over
the 9060 XT is a mere 3.6% across the
duration of the bench with the 8 GB
cards fairing badly owing to memory
limitations. Interestingly, when a card
is massively overcommitted, the extent
of the impact to performance can vary on
a runby-run basis. In the run you're
seeing here, the 5060 NTI makes it
through this part of the sequence with
no issues. But the Ti has big problems
with kind of strobing frame times there.
Further on, there's a gigantic collapse
to 8 GB performance, but weirdly the
5060 non TI recovers faster than the Ti.
Different runs would likely show
different issues, but the fact is that
even at 1080p, you will find games where
you run into problems on an 8 GB card,
which is why we do not recommend them,
regardless of whether they come from AMD
or Nvidia. Speaking of which, in the
5060 review, I quickly came up with some
VRAMm tests um based on not maxing
everything out in order to prove that
even with reasonable settings and
upscaling, you can still max out 8 GB of
memory. Once again, Marvel Spider-Man 2,
which supports FSR4 and DLSS, proves the
point. 5060 is running artificially slow
here owing to the lack of memory, but
the 16 GB cards have no problems at all.
In this case, the 5060 Ti has a 3%
advantage over 9060 XT. But the overall
point is that yes, budget cards running
with a 1440p output can accommodate raid
tracing. Just don't max everything out.
Moving across to Monster Hunter Wilds
again with realistic settings with high
RT enabled. The 8 gig 5060 keeps pace
for much of the benchmarking sequence
until this happens. Complete collapse as
we run out of memory. The 16 gig cards
are still delivering perfectly
reasonable performance though, so the
compute capabilities can clearly handle
RT, but 8 GB of RAM can't. The reason
I've included the 5068 gig here isn't so
much to show how bad the situation is
for the 5060 specifically, but also to
give you a hint of what could happen if
you do purchase the 8 GB version of the
9060 XT. Now, both of these games we've
just tested support FSR4 upscaling,
meaning you're getting excellent image
quality even at 1440p balanced. Both
support transformer model DLSS, so
Nvidia has excellent image quality, too.
But here's the thing. While FSR support
is gathering pace, Nvidia is always
ahead in terms of supported games going
back to 2020. AMD is seemingly always
playing catch up on features, and that
can't be factored out. FSR4 is a
brilliant first step, but looking at
AMD's Project Redstone, this is
effectively a promise to match Nvidia's
other features that have already
shipped. It's not quite good enough
because you know Nvidia isn't going to
stay still. It's going to continue to
innovate. So support for FSR4 is going
to be key for AMD. But right now there
is actually a tool called Optiscaler
that can actually help retrofit FSR4 to
a bunch more games. Works like this. You
copy its files into the game directory,
run through a quick setup file, and then
in game you can use the inputs from
other upscalers to feed FSR4. And when
it works, it's great. FSR3 on Cyberpunk
2077 looks really poor, but with
Optiscaler, the 1960 XT produces a
superb FSR4 image comparable to Nvidia
DLSS. This is a game with tight Nvidia
integration, though, so 5060 Ti is still
faster. It's ahead by 14 points in the
City streaming test we use. Um 1440p
balanced upscaling and ultra RT. Moving
on to taxing Phantom Liberty content,
the performance differentials remain the
same, but with lower frame rates. Even
so, Ultra RT on this game is no walk in
the park. There's further room for
optimized settings and improving frame
rates. But even here, it's 49 FPS on AMD
playing 56 FPS on Nvidia. Room here for
frame generation then, but that's
another story. Onto further custom
testing now, and I went into this one
with something on my mind. When PS5 Pro
was announced, various press went on a
mission to build a PC with similar specs
at a price point not a million miles
away from the pros $700. Well, back then
I anticipated that a GPU similar to a
downc clocked RTX 4070. It's probably
the closest GPU you could get, but that
was before RDNA4, before the 9060 XT,
and to be fair, before the 5060 Ti. Both
of these cards are pretty good at
achieving prolike performance levels,
sometimes with overhead to spare. Here's
Blackmmith Wukong. Not the most
optimized of console games, but a good
start. Performance mode on Pro still
runs at native 1080p. And while frame
generation is bafflingly used elsewhere,
the prologue stage does not use it. And
as we're running unlocked effectively,
we can compare our PC GPUs at the same
settings to the Pro. Well, I say the
same settings. We've got horsepower to
spare, meaning that I can use DLSS
performance mode, upscaling to 4K on the
5060 Ti, while I'm using the Optiscaler
mod on the 9060 XT to force on FSR4
performance mode. Same internal
resolution as Pro then, but with the
upscaling overhead on top. Even so, 5%
faster on 9060 XT versus Pro, rising to
27 points clear on 5060 Ti. One might
imagine that DLSS overhead is lower than
FSR4 here. Oh, and another change in
this comparison. Uh, the Pro version
mysteriously uses low quality textures.
I bumped that on to high when testing
the 9060 XT and 5060 Ti. More Pro
comparisons. Well, here in Fortza
Horizon 5, we're capped at 60 FPS on the
console. This version of the game has a
60fps performance mode that takes the
existing base console configuration and
spruces up environment settings, which
I've matched here. If it's not a
complete match, it's very, very close.
We can't see the full power of the Pro
here with that VSYNC cap, but both 9060
XT and 5060Ti average at over 70 fps
with a 2.7% lead for the 5060 Ti over
9060 XT. Native 4K on a so-called budget
card. Well, this is a game built for 4K
output on consoles, so it's no surprise
to see today's mainstream GPUs able to
do the same. Let's look at Alan Wakeake
2 next. We'll begin with a comparison to
PS5 Pro's performance mode. This
upscales from 864p to 4K using FSR2 with
quality settings equivalent to the base
conso's quality mode, which is
essentially PC's medium. This is easy to
replicate then and as the Pro is mostly
under 60 frames pers, we are finding the
limits of the GPU. 9060 XT 13% faster
than Pro 5060Ti is 10% ahead. So
certainly in rasterization terms, um
these cards are very close to what
Sony's $700 console is doing. But what
about RA tracing? Alan Wake 2. Next up,
we're going to be taking a look at the
quality mode uh capped to 30 frames
pers. Now here's the problem. The RT
setting on PS5 Pro is effectively lower
than PC's low. Even so, I thought I'd
give it a go. 4K output resolution using
FSR2 balance mode, effectively 1270p
internal. Then, as it is capped at 30,
we aren't seeing the pros full power.
But if we freeze frame here, we're
dipping beneath 30fps on the console.
So, we have found pro limits. You'll see
that both of our PC alternatives
struggle. We need that lower than low RT
setup to get a true measure of how close
we can get to the console experience.
Even so, I think we've proven out that
we're basically in the ballpark of PS5
Pro GPU performance across the board.
And with the 1960 XT, that performance
won't dwindle that much if you're
slotting the card into a PCIe gen 3based
PC. For $350, that's a very good deal,
even if the days of stratospherically
good genon GPU performance increases in
the mainstream market are long gone. So,
in summary, here's how I feel about the
1960 XT. Kind of slots into a market
defined by three Nvidia GPUs, only one
of which has enough memory in my
opinion. Well, based on my tests, you're
getting the lion's share of 5060Ti 16 GB
performance while being cheaper than the
8 GB model. assuming MSRP is real, of
course. Um, RT performance not as strong
as 5060Ti overall, but by and large,
Nvidia's performance isn't in line uh
with its higher price. 9060 XT clearly
offers better value. What Nvidia does
have is far far superior support for
upscaling, and Radeon users shouldn't
have to install mods to get FSR4 running
on more games. At the very least, FSR4
needs to hit FSR2 levels of adoption.
Frame gen support is also disappointing
right now on the AMD side. And while its
effectiveness lessens on budget level
cards, frame generation, multi-frame
generation, it does have utility,
especially when there are so many high
refresh rate monitors on the market
right now. I mean, this is Cyberpunk
2077 1440p display output, full RT
overdrive running on the RTX
5060Ti. Fay rates well north of 100
frames pers. Pretty decent high refresh
rate experience. Actually, the only
slight downer being that latency is a
bit on the high side, but perfectly fine
actually when using a controller. And I
think it would be remiss of me not to
point out that as good as the 9060 XT
is, sometimes those Nvidia features just
come together and produce something like
this. Pathfraced Cyberpunk 2077 on a
60class card. That is pretty special,
but it doesn't suddenly make the value
problems facing the 5060 Ti go away,
right? So, it's a tricky one, but
Nvidia's problem does diminish if it
gives the Ti model the price point it
actually deserves. The 16 GB model
shouldn't be more than $400 in my
opinion, max. And even without the
arrival of 9060 XT, the 5070 offers
proportionately more value than that 16
gig 5060 Ti. That's not what budget
gaming is all about. I've said it many
times, but price versus performance
should improve as you move down the
stack into the mainstream sector, not
get worse. We've crunched the numbers,
and here's how dollars per frame works
out. RTX 5068 GB is on top, but we'd
have to rule that out as a
recommendation simply because while our
benchmark games work fine at 1080p
overall, we've proven that AAA is a
problem for 8 GB cards going forward.
9060 XT 16 gigabytes is next, but
remarkably its RDNA4 stablemates follow
before we hit the
5060Ti. The 8 GB version of the 5060Ti
model won't have the longevity we expect
from the card. So, we need to factor
that out. And there we go. 5070 is
offering better value than the 16 GB TI.
That needs to change. And here's that
same table at 1440p resolution. 9070 and
9070 XT deliver proportionately better
value followed by 5060 and 5070. Dodgy
pricing and diminishing performance
combined to show that the TI cards place
beneath that. Again, good evidence that
a price adjustment is needed. Of course,
do bear in mind that these are our
benchmarks and our mix of Raster and RT.
Other outlets will have a different mix
and different games and therefore
different results. But that's all for me
on this one, which means I can revert to
the standard appeals for likes, shares,
subscriptions, bell ringing, whatever.
And yes, please do consider backing all
of our work via the DF supporter
program. High-quality video downloads of
everything we do, weekly news updates
from the team, a team you can actually
interact with on our Discord, early
access to a bunch of stuff, including
DFDirect weekly. Oh, and occasional
bonus material, too. Finally, please
check out store.digitalfoundry.net net
for our merchandising wares. Hope you
enjoyed this one in the meantime, but
for now, thanks for watching and
supporting Digital Foundry.